[Music]
uh
it's like water coming up the beach
it goes where the the sand is flattest
first and then it gets to the steep bits
later and this is what we've been seeing
all the time is that the water goes the
waves go forward the waves come back the
waves go forward the waves come back so
putin brought the waves forward in april
and put lots of troops in in a round and
then took some of them back and
everybody breathed a sigh of relief and
and then he did his zapad exercise and
everybody breathed a sigh of relief
after it went finished and now here we
are again this time the waves are
getting up to the steep bits if this
wave is not the one there will be
another one and there will be another
one
if he says this fine it makes good good
television it makes good uh newspapers
and everybody goes
but actually it's untrue
they may go back but it's not uh in the
big picture it's nothing even if he
pulls 50 50 000 or 70 000 of them back
in the big picture it's nothing because
he has already moved forward and we're
further up the beach and he's not
stopping i mean the russian encircle
encirclement
is is very clear in what what it does is
it stretches the ukrainian defense
forces
and that's the key element of it is to
actually to to make it almost impossible
for uh the ukrainian general staff to
anticipate exactly where russia will
attack some of them are actually on the
border
like 10 kilometers back just ready to to
go down a road all the military analysts
that i know who look at this as opposed
to the political analysts who think
differently about it the military
analysts just suck their teeth in and
say you know he's ready
it leaves us now
actually exactly the same as we were
yesterday
still waiting to see what they're going
to do properly and not waiting for words
but waiting for actions